hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
here's a fun puzzle that's been
spreading around the internet
i wanted to make a video to present the
correct answer
i also wanted to show another
interpretation if you pay very careful
attention to all of the details in the
puzzle
i believe there is a real answer to this
puzzle that involves higher level and
complicated mathematics
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
[Music]
so how can we solve this system of
equations
we'll start out by solving each equation
in turn the first equation has three red
balloons equal to thirty
since ten plus ten plus ten is equal to
thirty we can solve that a single red
balloon is equal to ten
we'll use this value to solve the second
equation
we have a red balloon plus a pair of
green balloons plus a pair of green
balloons is equal to 18.
the red balloon is equal to 10
and then we have two of the pairs of
green balloons
and this all equals eighteen
we can then solve that a pair of green
balloons is equal to four
we then have a pair of green balloons
minus a pair of blue balloons equal to
two since the pair of green balloons is
four we can then solve that the pair of
blue balloons has to be equal to two
so now we need to evaluate a single blue
balloon
plus a single red balloon multiplied by
a single green balloon
how can we do that
well if this puzzle is about counting
balloons which is a reasonable
assumption
then we can take the single value to be
half of the pair
so a single green balloon will be equal
to half of four which is two
and a single blue balloon will be equal
to one
we then substitute in these values
we have 1 plus 10 multiplied by 2.
this also presents a landmine for some
people
you have to remember to do 10 times 2
which equals 20 first because of the
order of operations
so we have 1 plus 20 and that equals 21.
now this is the most commonly accepted
answer to this puzzle
but i think the real answer should
encapsulate all of the visual details
so here are some key details i think we
should consider
if you look at the pair of green
balloons and the pair of blue balloons
the green and blue paired balloons are
facing different directions
also
for all of the balloons the arrows on
the balloons are used for the strings
so these arrows bring to mind knuts up
arrow notation which suggests that we
should be considering exponentiation and
tetration
and before i explain how that changes
the answer
i want to say don't tell me that this is
overthinking the puzzle they keep saying
that you need to be a genius to solve
these puzzles so i don't think it's
beyond the realm of these puzzles to use
higher level mathematics
so how does this affect the final answer
we'll first consider the pair of green
balloons if we let a single green
balloon be represented by the variable x
this translates into x left superscript
of x is equal to 4.
how do we interpret this notation
well a up arrow up arrow n is equal to a
left superscript of n
which is equal to a power tower where we
have a raised to the power of a raised
to the power of a
a total of n minus 1 times
this translates into x raised to the
power of x raised to the power of x
where we have a power tower of x terms
so how do we solve this
well i don't know the general method for
solving this kind of equation
but for this particular equation we can
make a lucky guess
notice that 2 left superscript of 2 is
equal to 2 to the power of 2 which
equals 4.
in other words
x equals 2 satisfies this equation
so we figured out that the value of a
single green balloon is equal to two
now we did all this work and we
ultimately ended up with exactly the
same value for a single green balloon as
before
so i think that's a fun coincidence now
let's use this interpretation for the
pair of blue balloons
if we let a single blue balloon be
denoted by the variable y
this visual puzzle would translate into
y to the power of y is equal to 2.
how can we solve this equation
we'll use the lambert w function which
is the inverse of the function
x times e to the power of x
if x times e to the power of x is equal
to z
we then have x is equal to w of z
we don't know its explicit form but if
we have something like x times e to the
power of x we can take its inverse to
solve for x
so how does that help us solve the
equation y to the power of y is equal to
2
well the first thing we'll do is we'll
rewrite the equation
it can be rewritten as e to the power of
lny raised to the power of e to the
power of ln y
this is because e to the power of l and
y is equal to y
now we'll use exponentiation rules to
simplify this as e raised to the power
of ln y times e raised to the power of
lny
we can now take the natural log of both
sides so that we get the natural log of
y
times the quantity e to the power of l
and y is equal to the natural log of 2.
so now notice a pattern in this equation
if we let a be equal to the natural log
of y
we have a times e to the power of a
equal to the natural log of 2. so we can
use the lambert w function here to solve
for a
we have that a is equal to w of the
natural log of 2.
now we'll go back and substitute that a
is equal to the natural log of y
and then we'll take e to the power of
both sides so we can solve that y is
equal to e
to the power of w of the natural log of
2 which is approximately 1.56
note that i calculated this in wolfram
alpha so i calculated w of natural log
of 2 as product log of the natural log
of 2.
so this means we have the value for a
single blue balloon being equal to e to
the power of w of the natural log of 2
which is approximately 1.56
so we now take this value for the single
blue balloon
and we then need to evaluate a blue
balloon plus a red balloon multiplied by
a green balloon
so we substitute in our values
and we get this is approximately equal
to 21.56
and i believe this is the real answer to
this puzzle
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video
these math videos inspire and build
confidence for people around the world
and they've already accumulated over a
hundred million views
i believe if society truly valued
mathematics we'd have millions of
subscribers and billions of views
please help this goal
you can subscribe for free to get the
newest videos please watch and share all
the mind your decisions videos that's
one of the best ways for people to
discover this channel
you can email me a puzzle or math topic
presh mindyourdecisions.com
you can also support this channel
financially by checking out my books
which are great for gifts they're linked
in the video description
and you can support on patreon to earn
exclusive rewards
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support